well there are they really are a staple
in southern nevada and tonight the lee's
liquor family continues to mourn the
death of their founder and now their
heir kenny lee was killed over the
weekend in a car crash christian casares
joining us live in the west valley with
more on how the lee empire
impacted southern nevada
that's right guys good evening well the
name lee's at discount laker is a very
well known brand here in the valley the
family growing the business for the past
35 years take a look like this is just
one of many stores
across here in the valley 23 stores to
be exact employees here tell me kenny
lee was here on wednesday and tonight
they are still shocked over his
death i feel sad for the family a few
months after the passing of the founder
of one of nevada's largest liquor store
empires another loss for the family
kenny lee was killed over the weekend in
a fatal crash on highway 93 their father
and then they just lost somebody else
just recently
it's sad to hear according to nhp the 53
year old ceo was in a 2019 dodge grand
caravan and was not wearing a seatbelt
instantly condolences from the community
flooded social media
leo writing very sad news to a staple
business in las vegas for many years
dee's post reads i've always loved their
commercials and know that they've been
very generous to the vegas community my
condolences to the lee family i feel
like i knew him and his father
personally their memorable ads embedded
within their customers for 35 years and
while others benefited from the family's
programs and partnerships brian prescape
worked with the family for over 20 years
they didn't do it because they were
trying to promote their business they
didn't do it because they thought it
would be
they did it because
they really cared about the
organizations that they supported lee is
survived by his wife and his three
children nathan morgan and addie hard to
imagine what the family is going through
right now
without
without kenny without mr lee
back out here live a public vigil will
be held this friday at 9 30 in the
morning at the corner of azor and at
tania way we're told that more than 500
red balloons will be released
to remember lee all that information is
on our website 8newsnow.com christian
gossett is live local now